ich bin Konrad Schuller korresparente
Frankfurter Allgemeinen
Sonntagszeitung im Augenblick in der
westo klinischen Großstadt Lemberg
Ukrainisch
Igls
Lemberg hat im Augenblick noch keine
aktiven Kriegshandlungen erlebt aber die
Stadt ist natürlich in hoher Anspannung
viele Familien haben ihre Angehörigen an
der Front es gibt die Sorge vor
sogenannten diversanten
deshalb gibt es eine Renten gibt es
überall Kontrollpunkte die
Ausweise kontrollieren für Fälschungen
zu identifizieren versuchen und es gibt
vor allem am Bahnhof einen enormen
Rückstau von Flüchtlingen weit von
Lemberg aus die Züge nach Polen fahren
man sieht auch dass die Mobilisierung
der Bevölkerung ihr Wirkung hat es gibt
lange Schlangen vor den vor dem
bergkommissariaten wo man sich als
Freiwilliger melden kann es gibt
Schlangen vor Waffengeschäften wo man
sich gewähren Pistolen in einem
vereinfachten Verfahren kaufen kann um
sich in einem solchen
freiwilligenverband auch selber
auszulüsten wenn ich genug Waffen aus
dem Depot des Staates da sind es gibt
Schlangen vor den Schießständen wo Leute
schießen lernen und ansonsten aber ist
die Versorgungslage allgemein stabil
nachdem es im ersten Tagen Hamsterkäufe
gegeben hat haben die Leute erstmal
anscheinend wäre Reserven aufgefüllt es
gibt immer wieder luftalarme aber keine
Luftangriffe
nach Baden in den Kellern
und tauschen die nächsten die neuesten
Nachrichten aus und was auffällt ist das
so gut wie jeder mit dem ich bis dahin
gesprochen habe
zuversichtlich ist das die Ukraine
diesen Krieg gewinnen wird weil man sagt
in die russischen Soldaten sind zwar
mehr aber die sind mentale auf einen
richtigen Krieg mit Blutvergießen nicht
vorbereitet und sie haben so oft man
hier auch nicht die Motivation zu
kämpfen und die jemand hat der also
keine sein Land verteidigt
Flüchtlinge sind bei aller straparts
halbwegs mit einem Minimalversorgung
ausgestattet es gibt dann den am Bahnhof
erzählte wo man wo man sich wenn man es
nicht in die Bahnhofshalle hinein
geschafft hat recht und schlecht in der
Nacht unterstellen kann während er
während der Polizeistunde am
yamatischsten ist die Trennung der
Familien weil die Männer nicht mit
dürfen wenn sie zwischen 18 und 60 sind
weil sie dann der Mobilisierung
unterliegen und Familien sich
entscheiden müssen ob sie zusammen
bleiben wollen oder ob Sie die Frauen
und Kinder in Sicherheit bringen wollen
es gibt dann manchmal
sehr trauriges Szene
[Musik]